okay so
welcome back to day five of the digital
marketing certified associate course i
hope you had a good weekend or rather i
hope you had a good week
and your weekend has just about begun
um i will start off with a quick recap
of where we were
last week
so we got an introduction into social
media
right that's where we were
i walked you through the details of
options of what how social media
basically
uh plays an integral role in today's
world where businesses want to make sure
that they get noticed
i spoke about how you have blogs which
are very very
powerful in being able to
ensure multiple things in terms of
getting a ton of volumes in in terms of
traffic to your website it also helps
you get established as a thought leader
in your space
and i also briefly spoke about how you
want to design your editorial calendar
to make sure that you have content
uh you know coming up through the year
at specific intervals so that is where
we were with respect to uh the
introduction we continue the journey
today
and we will commence with
micro blogs right so when we look at
micro blogs
uh we are essentially looking at
platforms where you you know you send in
very short messages
um and the leader amongst micros amongst
micro blogging platforms is clearly
twitter and we'll learn a lot more about
that in today's session
so micro blocking essentially is as you
can see short quick
measured messages
short sentences you want to build
followership you want to build
engagement and micro blogging is really
an effective way to broadcast your
message because you really have
don't have too much of space to say too
many things unlike other platforms like
facebook for instance where you can
create long form posts so here this is
really about uh you know micro blogs are
used as a broadcasting tool we wouldn't
want to get into too many uh platforms
there and the focus is going to be
twitter
so the the whole point is this you
already communicate
and today the communication channel has
evolved and while these channels do
exist where you have phone you have
you have radio you have all the
traditional networks it has moved on to
social networks which is why
today when you listen to
radio right you will see a lot of brands
advertising and cross-promoting their
digital assets
a radio channel would say if you like
the show you know tweet
back to us
or a promo or a 10 second ad or a jingle
on your radio channel will basically
also promote a twitter facebook page
that the company has so it has become a
hybrid
cross promotion today uh that's how
you know communicators broadcast and
that's how things work the key benefits
uh it's quick it's easy most micro
blogging in fact all micro blogging
platforms that there are have um
[Music]
you can have mobile users as the
predominant uh
you know platform from where people blog
or send messages so it just takes a few
seconds
you can use multiple devices but the
mobile phone seems to be the preferred
platform especially for micro blogging
and uh you can select whom you want to
follow you can select the topics you
want to look into you can do all of that
stuff
and you can connect to other platforms
via your micro blog so that's again
something that i will i will show you in
time
all right so continuing with our journey
micro blogging we're looking at twitter
it has a tremendous user base it has an
amazing array of app choices
and it also has very powerful search
functionality now let me just look at
that
um
yeah absolutely
right so thanks for that so let me just
quickly log in and look into some of the
links that i can share
so app choices as i mentioned you have
um
i'll look at the apps there
fundamentally when we look at the
adoption we're looking at
close to 320 million
monthly active users worldwide okay so
that is the kind of reach that you have
with a micro blogging platform such as
twitter in fact
i shouldn't say such as twitter this is
specific to twitter so you have more
than 320 million subscribers
i'm just sharing my
twitter screen here my twitter app
so this for instance is my um
my twitter handle
right
and we will look
into this in a while
um app choices you have
a lot of apps a you have the native
twitter app that you can download and
use whether it's an ios or an android
device
you can also do a lot of advanced stuff
you have you know tools like tweet bot
uh you have you know
tweet both again for apple devices what
it does if you're a power user of
twitter you will understand that you
know these enhance your uh your
abilities further
okay
so we have tools like tweetbot and i'm
going to show you that
so these applications basically um for
those of you who are new to twitter
these applications are these these tools
right tweetbot it basically is uh it
kind of does advanced stuff it helps you
manage your lists better it is ideally
for a little more advanced users people
who use the channel it basically also
cuts down ads you can clean that up and
as you can see it is you know improved
user profiles optimized status details
so this is if you have a ios phone if
you have an apple device then this
becomes a preferred
app
and then there are
there's a similar app called tweet
caster for android
okay so this is your
and there are several tools there are
several niche tools a lot of tools that
you know most of us wouldn't use that is
very very advanced that is for
professional marketers who have
uh you know who keep looking at twitter
as a source of business networking and
messaging and advertising so there are
those many tools as well so look at this
10 million users have have actually
downloaded tweetcaster
so this is what uh entry customers again
is for um
android devices very similar to what
tweet bot does so it is enhancing your
twitter user experience fundamentally
that's what it is
and you have a strong array of network
choices what do i mean by that
right network integration so you are
able to now through your twitter account
uh
distribute advertisements that can go
across multiple apps which are non
twitter apps so somebody's playing a
video game you should download a video
game that you're playing on you know
farmville or any of those games that you
download and run and play on your mobile
device which has nothing to do with the
twitter app
through the twitter advertising platform
you can also make sure that your ads
appear on those apps so that is the
power of the network integration that
twitter
provides in fact uh your tweets and your
twitter ads can now go and you know
reach across more than a billion unique
devices through
twitter and you know through your
twitter ads
then you also have advanced search
functionality so not only can you do
amazing amount of searches on twitter
let me just demonstrate that to you if
i'm on twitter if i want to search for
um
whatever right
molded
plastics
right so as you can see there's so many
accounts or there are these companies or
individuals
that have molded plastics in their
twitter handle so twitter handle is your
name on twitter so for me for example if
you look at the url my twitter handle is
at the rate
this
so if i'm looking for molded plastics i
have this
or i can also just hit a search
now not only will twitter out of those
320 million and there are 320 million
active users there are more users who
are not really very active so twitter
basically searches through all of that
and gives you a bunch of tweets right
you see this
in this example this is the profile of
this brand of this company
this is a company they have you know
molded plastics in their
information here
so you see molded products and that is
how this word has come up and then this
has molded and plastics that's why this
account has come up and their tweet is
visible
these this is a list of top tweets this
tells you which is live so which
messages are being tweeted right now
with the word molded plastics in it and
as you can see here's one and this
happened on april 24th
well that isn't too recent so let me
just look at molded plastics as one word
if i want to search for a word what i
typically do is this
right i search for molded plastics and
as you can see now
twitter is looking for tweets that have
this exactly the way it is without a
space molded plastics so here in the
profile i see molded plastics
if i look at live
let me see if there's anybody tweeting
with this
not right now and then let me try the
same word with a hashtag
if there is no hashtag designed for this
word you will not see a hashtag but if i
look at the hashtag and i say plastic
let me see if this gives me some results
okay
here i'm getting something right you see
this hash plastic hash pollution so
people use hashtags on twitter hashtags
again works very well on uh instagram
and those a bunch of other tools as well
hashtags also work for facebook but um i
have not seen hashtags being used very
very heavily on facebook because on
facebook you basically tend to tag
people like that groups that you want
to you want them to notice your messages
and the other techniques you use on
facebook and other platforms but on
twitter
hashtag is a very powerful way to get
noticed as you can see here
and let us say if somebody has put the
music industries battle against plastic
junk so that seems to be the theme
and here there's also music so now i'm
shifting and looking at music
as the world around which i want to
search for content on twitter
if you see this hashtag on my search
change to music i could also remove hash
and search for music
i will still get a lot of
tweets that has the word music in them
right but a more effective way to
discover tweets with the word music you
see this now music is here
in the
description of the
twitter handle
music is again here there's music here
there's music here but if i want to look
at the tweets with the word music in it
i'm going to use a hash
and now you see that the word music is
in the hashtags
so there's all this music here and
there's music here and these are all the
top tweets the tweets that have been
retweeted that have been liked the most
that are very very popular and if i want
to see what is happening right now the
most recent live tweet with the word ash
music in it
um
anyway all right so this is an example
of tweets with the with hash music in it
because that is the
word that i'm searching for so this is
the account this is how search works and
if you go on to google
and if i'm looking for
i'm searching for something recent
searching for
plastic
right um
there's a lot of plastic related
information
but if i look for plastic on google with
hash
right
now i can also see you see this
instagram tweets with the with hashtag
plastic i can see twitter feeds with
hash plastic so these are all
tweets if i look at this
right
as you can see there are multiple posts
that have come up with hash plastic so
my tweets also become searchable that is
the whole point
okay
so these are all
tweets that are searchable now on google
so this is what it is uh you have
tremendous uh ability to search around
any topic that you're interested in
news and updates is really what people
use twitter for for the bulk of
their social media needs and of course
twitter is also used for listening
listening into customer conversations
opinions that people are sharing and
what people have to say
about a brand or a product
right what do people share typically
these are instances of examples of
what people use how many of you actually
use twitter heavily
if you do just let me know on the chat
window
if you don't that's also fine
if you don't put a message on chat on
the chat window i'm going to assume that
you are not heavily using twitter
okay
yeah so then i can basically then go
deeper if i need to based on your
uh understanding of the platform
so these are examples of you know what
kind of links people share on twitter
and as you can see people put in their
messages with short links right bitly
flicks so this is an example of how
people put in their messages
right their questions their opinions are
controversial
bits of information that keep coming in
and people keep putting up their
information so that's how twitter works
because of that the guideline is that
you don't become a twitter wanderer
because on twitter it is extremely easy
to get lost you can just keep going you
can keep jumping you know hashtags and
you will always keep going into
interesting articles interesting
information whatever topic you choose
now look at this trends
these are the hashtags that seem to be
trending
right so if i look at this
i don't know what this is i can do it
2016. so let's take a look this seems to
be the
high trending
and if i keep scrolling i can keep going
down and i keep looking
right
so okay
this seems to be
dr wayne dyer who passed away
yeah very entire butterfly story so
humorous i can do it
so basically people seem to be tweeting
around uh this person who's who was a a
spiritual guide leader
speaker motivational speaker etc
and these hashtags seem to be in line
with
something to do with him i will have to
dig deeper to find out why him this is
wayne dyer this is a person
and
this seems to be a hashtag trending in
his memory
but this is how you have trending
hashtags right
so prabhab uh no uh even if you missed
last week's classes you do want to
certainly take a look at the recordings
but it is fine if you can just join in
what i'm covering today is independent
of what you've seen um in the previous
sessions today is all about social media
so i'm going to walk through various
social media channels what you can do
with them etc so
that's fine okay
so this is an example of how you look at
hashtags
so don't be a twitter monitor decide
what you want to do on twitter and why
you are there so establish clear goals
the goals that you should have from a
business perspective
is build credibility and that is one of
the ways that is one of the most popular
the reasons why businesses organizations
and companies use twitter and so do
individuals right um so it builds
credibility
you want to spark interest build buzz
and circulate links and broadcast your
links to your blogs to your videos to
your facebook page to your contests to
your coupons to whatever it is that you
want to get people's attention towards
you want to listen at just and pivot
listen meaning you want to listen to
what people are saying
about your brand
and you might want to use that as
feedback and do and go back in fact a
lot of companies as i said have recently
started recently building over the last
few years has started integrating their
twitter account into their customer
service department
so there are people so if you go to you
know a lot of brands do this if you're
looking at let us say
customer service
you will see a lot of brands having you
know listening uh platform listening uh
posts using twitter
um
in india twitter is a new tool to troll
political parties and celebrities but
he's just twitter for customer service
from indian government is remarkable
yeah yeah
so as i said a lot of brands a lot of
businesses across are adopting to this
if you look at a company let's say um
uh goldridge appliances gold rates is a
very popular brand for those of you in
india would recognize this brand
instantly they are into multiple
businesses so if i let us say i'm
looking at gold rage appliances
and i want to get goldridge appliances
to listen to me have a complaint to make
right or i really want them to notice
something
i don't follow them they don't follow me
right that's the way it is at this point
in the match you can see this follow
button is uh it says follow which means
i am not yet following
this account so if i click on this then
i start following this account but right
now i don't want to i let us assume i
want to send a complaint
to them saying you know my refrigerator
isn't working or something what i will
do is i'll take a note of their twitter
handle
okay
and i can go and
click tweet this appears in my own
twitter headline so i'm gonna say
uh my
my recent goldridge appliance
uh
i
last week
isn't
working
okay
so if i do this what happens is this
tweet appears on my timeline
since i have mentioned at the rate
goldridge appliance it is directly going
to go into goldridge appliances
notifications so if they go into their
notifications like if i they will see a
message saying message from me saying
that you know this is a a
a complaint or something that i have put
they get a notification because i put
the at the rate go through this
appliance in my tweet and they're going
to notice that so i will i will show
this to you how it works so now i'm
going home i'm going to meeting my
twitter account
right so here if i go into notifications
and then there are specific messages
sent to me with at the rate program
online then those are the messages that
i will see here
as you can see there are people who have
sent me messages directly these are
people who are following me which is why
you don't see the at the rate but if you
look at mentions
you see this at the rate program online
thank you for attending the grand
opening so red academy is thanking me
and they have put this so i get this not
only in my twitter stream but i also get
this in my mentions and based on my
settings i can choose to make sure that
you know if i am being mentioned uh by
on any tweet by anybody anywhere in the
world then i need to get to direct email
so all of those are opportunities or
ways in which
um
you know brands and companies listen to
what people have to say and
connect and listen and you know build
credibility yeah
there's a button under the name we can
tweet from there too yeah yeah
absolutely
okay
then we have retweets
this goes to their public feed uh if you
put at the rate mentioned it is going to
be on your public feed but it is going
to go to them in their mentions since
you don't follow them yet it may not go
into their main feed but if you're
following them it could have okay
tweets are limits as you can see here
140 character messages
yeah retweets tweets that are reposted
by another user
uh
retweets are very very powerful right so
let's look at this example
if there's an article here and this
person is tweeting this right so let us
say you have these social icons and you
know she clicked on one of these social
icons to
to share this page as a link on her
twitter account
let's say she has these many followers
and there are people who are following
her right so in all their uh
feeds they will typically see this tweet
coming in because they're following her
right
out of the people that are following her
let's assume that these six people chose
to retweet that message
they saw this you see this icon it is
basically a retweet account and in turn
they have an average of 100 followers
you're looking at 202 retweets into
average of 100 followers 20 000
plus users are going to basically get
access
so the way it works is this
right i'm just going to go to my home
and i'll show you how this happens live
so here you see this is these are all
the streams people business insider has
tweeted something and because i follow a
business insider you see this there's
this tick mark which says that i'm
already following them
uh their twitter messages come into my
twitter feed
now if i like this
i can click on this and retweet now this
already has been retweeted twice
or it has been liked by three people so
if i retweet this
click on retweet i can add a comment
and i retweet this right so look at what
i have retweeted so if i want to look at
only my tweets i go into this
this exclusively lists my tweets
and
this is an example of my retweet
right this tweet this tweet was
originally tweeted by inc
this says that i retweeted this right it
says you retweeted which is you meaning
me in this context
and
it has been retweeted by 39 others
that's what this is
here's an example where i have again
retweeted this message but in my message
i have also put in these hashtags
to kind of you know get this noticed one
person has like this and if i look at
twitter activity
on my version of the tweet this tweet
has received 166 impressions which means
166 people
should have seen this retweet that i
tweeted
and two people have clicked on the
profile one person has liked it this is
what we are trying to or i'm trying to
demonstrate here when i look at the
power of retweets so this is the kind of
place where it works amazingly well as a
broadcast medium so why have i used
hashtags digital marketing email geeks
because this is topical this tweet is
relevant to audiences who are interested
in these topics
and people who are following these
topics with a hashtag will be able to
discover my tweet
and that is the whole idea
right
so there are different things that i
have tweeted about
right here i've said 100
inbound marketing statistics
and if i want if i click on this
[Music]
share by direct message copy link to
tweet embed tweet i can pin the second
whatever
and if i look at the tweet activity this
tweet has gone to 147 people
so that is how i can actually measure
what is the popularity of each tweet
i can go very advanced i can look at
this this is a brief analytics it tells
me that over the last one week i have
earned 1074 impressions
through a variety of tweets
and this tells me the number of
impressions i gained on each of these
days in the last week
right and in due course i will also show
you the analytics to give you a sense of
how i can analyze these details further
to see which were my most popular tweets
which were the tweets that um who who is
following me the most all of that is
what i can analyze so that gets into
analytics and measurement
i'll get there in a while so this is why
retweets matter
and then you have a concept called lists
when you build a list what happens is um
it is like putting some structure to the
twitter activity right so if there are
millions of people tweeting and you're
following a lot of twitter accounts
you very specifically want to let us
assume let us say want to follow uh
conversations around a topic
or you want to basically be on top of
what a bunch of individuals are saying
with respect to a particular topic
in this example right
jennifer is following she's created a
list called market motor
and she has you know she's following 13
and four and the four people out of this
13 people are following her
and these are people on the list
now your list can also include people
whom you do not follow
like i am on a list of several uh i'm on
myself i'm on several lists i don't know
them people have come they've seen my
tweets they've liked what i'm tweeting
and they've added me onto their list
okay
if your followers receive your tweets it
will be considered as impressions yes
correct
so this is an example of a list where i
can build my own list while lists work
i can create a group
around an industry based on my interest
i can quickly access specific topics
because otherwise you know every second
there's somebody tweeting about
something if i'm following you know 5000
people
there's such a lot of twitter noise
going on it's like a constant unending
chatter and i want to distill only those
tweets that matter to me for my business
i want to know if somebody is searching
for my products so out of thousands and
millions of tweets that i might
potentially see in a day
i very specifically want to look at you
know either brand mentions or if people
are talking about complaints or if
people are talking about
requirements that i can satisfy as a
business so i can create multiple lists
this also helps in building up goodwill
you can end up discovering
voices and people who are either your
fans or people who have unique opinions
and you know you can basically look into
their recommendations and opinions and
help in your own business endeavors
and you can follow people without
following them because you include them
into your
list
right so this is how it works
i can go in here
i can get into settings and i get into
my lists
right if i click on lists
then as you can see i have created two
lists there are two lists here
this has three members and this has
three members
in this list i'm calling it marketing
infographics but really what this list
is all about is identifying a bunch of
people as you can see here
recently i had members i can view all to
see all members
who are on this list i have three at the
moment it is listing all three of them
this is what the list is it's a public
list that i have created
the three members and your subscribers
so i can edit this i can change this
marketing
insights
and i can give a description
i can say you know retweets around
infographics little digital marketing
and i can keep it as a private list or
as a public list
okay
and then
tweets specifically by these individuals
who are part of this list
are you know tweets that i see in this
case i happen to be following all these
three even if i was not following them i
could still include them in my list
right as you can see there are tweets
from these individuals or these
people have added to my list
so this is an example of how list works
okay
what should we tracking on twitter
customer service as i mentioned
buzz and chatter who's talking about
your brand who's
uh saying something positive who's
saying something negative who's neutral
uh
right impact on sales so if you've tried
if you're on if you're a business if
you're doing you know a funnel you're
doing a shopping cart activity
and you know what is the impact that you
know people are making on your sales if
people are returning your products what
are people talking about because not all
times do you know you know people don't
necessarily
send you direct customer feedback forms
they don't fill in there but people go
and you know
talk about whatever they have to say on
their social channels
so you want to listen to that and see
what the impact is happening on your
sales the traffic and the links so
looking at building traffic and link
building through twitter
these are ways in which you can
attract a lot of
traffic so look at this example right
neil patel has said how to create mobile
friendly content and there's a link
that directly links to his blog post
where he is talking about an article
related to how to create mobile friendly
content
right so this is an example of how you
could include your own links
and tweet about your links on your
twitter account
okay
there are plenty of tools that as i said
can help you improve the power of your
twitter handle you can integrate tweets
into your blog into your site in fact
wordpress has a plugin where you can
open your twitter feeds into your
wordpress blog so on your homepage you
can have a small section there where the
most recent tweets are shown on your own
website homepage so you can integrate
tweets
you have dedicated programs and tools
and desktop apps that you can uh
build and use which are twitter powered
you have mobile apps like i showed you
tweetbot you know
you know those kinds of uh tools
twitter itself gives you schedulers
lists you have an account management
tools that you can integrate it's very
very convenient it helps you manage your
entire twitter presence
we looked at search and you can also
research influencers
you want to know who influencers are
with your industry this is a very very
powerful way to do that
okay
so let me just look at that um give me
the name of any topic that you might
want to look for or your industries
let's say
used bikes
furnitures okay
furniture so if i'm talking about
furniture and if i'm distributing
furniture if i'm in that business
uh i want to look at accounts that have
the word furniture in them so let me see
these are all the profiles
that have furniture see aspiring
furniture markets
i don't know who this person is but as
you can see this person seems to be
pretty popular she's following so many
people she has close to 8 000 followers
and she's very very heavily
uh you know
an adapter or a user of twitter
loves british design etc
so if i were to dig deeper and see who
this person is
i can tell if this person might be
interested in the kind of products that
i sell
right this person is in
this geography in this region
and this is what the person is
interested in
okay
so that is how i can put a word and then
search for specific individuals or
people
who are tweeting about it in different
geographies
right look at this
she has basically put in a tweet it's a
conversation
and i can also use this and if there are
multiple people who have
responded to this particular chain of
communication
right see look me at this this person
says
again this person is a fairly powerful
influencer as you can see
this person has a very very uh
formidable
twitter presence
and will be getting furniture and solar
energy after vacation so she is talking
about this open two more schools in this
geography
and there is this conversation happening
60 people have retweeted it have liked
it so obviously if you are looking at
furniture sales and if you are in uh
this
if this
geography is of relevance to you
then this person could be a very
powerful influencer if this person
happens to like what you tweet and
retweet this
your tweets can potentially reach
18 thousand three hundred followers
right and get noticed in a very very big
way
or this question just sir please stop
assembling your foot inside the parking
lot
right so
this has been like 127 people
right so this is one of the ways in
which you can discover
who is really the influencer
there is
another tool that i can show you
called follower wonk
okay
how exactly can we influence them to
follow us great question carol hang in
there and i'm going to show this to you
um in a while
okay
so this is the tool to
discover
influencers on twitter it's called
follower wonk
as you can see uh this is really what
the tool is i can look at
such bios so search the profiles and
bios of people and then i want to say
that i want to look at people who have
the word furniture
in their bio but not only their twitter
profiles or bios i want to look at more
options
i want to specifically look for those
people who are in mumbai
okay
or any other city that you might want to
propose which whatever the city you want
to look at
is mumbai okay
or you want to look at some of the
geography
okay i'll go with that
and if i search
okay the data below is limited by my
current subscription
i haven't yet subscribed which is okay
i'm not logged in either
but if i just look for people who are
who have something with furniture who
are based out of this city in india
then i see 150 of 131 results
and this has been stacked in a
descending order based on the number of
followers that these people have
so well this company seems to be a
powerful influencer
they seem to have a lot of uh followers
and there's something called social
authority which this tool assigns right
so the tool assigns this authority
ranking
based on their own internal parameters
on how many shares is person getting how
frequently does this person tweet what
happens etc
and this seems to be the statistics so
if i really want people to pick up my
messages on twitter and relay them and
if there are people specifically in
mumbai
then these are the potential people whom
i can see this click to learn how to
establish an app follow and unfollow or
i can just click on this and follow
these people
okay
but if i'm looking at
london
there are all these people
who tweet or who have an interest in
furniture you can see this the living
room tom dixon studio
uh and then there are individuals
like jason wolf interior design and
furniture blog breaking architectural
and interior design and furniture news
now if you want
to get your word across to markets in
london
then you may want to get this person to
follow you
uh observe what you're tweeting and if
it is of relevance then jason is
naturally going to pick up that message
and retweet it and you know become an
influencer
of your brand uh if he takes to liking
your messages likes your brand likes
landing page and your content
and as you can see there's a list of
followers that he has
so that's really what it is if i remove
all these qualifiers then
twitter basically profiles the most
popular people on twitter
right it appears that like katy perry is
the most popular then there's justin
bieber and then there are a lot of these
people
names and businesses and brands that you
already recognize
very very popular you have all these
names here because i have not looked at
a specific criteria it's an open search
right this is katy perry's
twitter account
i'm not following her neither is she
following me
that's what it is
right
so this tool is very powerful to be able
to identify whom to follow who's
following you
and again if i were to look for
people within a specific geography i
want to know who are the most popular
profiles
in um
in zurich
switzerland
i don't put a name so i'm not looking
for somebody with a specific criteria
i'm just randomly searching for the most
more popular people in switzerland
and there seems to be these i don't know
who they are
but these seem to be the more popular
people there
or i can remove a location and i can
just say i want to know
who are the real influencers in politics
and then it gives me these
interesting
details
why am i getting this
let me see again
okay this is because the word politics
is mentioned in their twitter handles as
you can see this
right
or if i put a general term saying uh
social trends
so it's it's it's it's very very
exhausting you can keep doing this all
day long and it gives you this
uh if you're saying finance or you know
uh money
or investment investing
or let us say invest
right
then these are people and brands that
seem to be extremely popular on twitter
and they are all looking to
invest is you know in their
bio which is the reason why these
accounts seem to have popped up fifty
thousand results about of relevance
showing one to fifty
right
so this is a very very powerful way
or you can just change this to let us
say
band
so if you're into music if you want to
sell some software to do with music apps
music downloads and if you want to look
at bands that are popular and you want
them to pick up your message
i play in a band
show to other people in my band and this
person michael clifford
as you can see here
is extremely popular
um
right
and you see this followers likes
following so if you have let us say a
musical device a music instrument that
you want to sell and you want this
person to you know talk about your brand
in a positive way you may want to give
and i'm going to give you some tips on
how to build your
track of influencers how to reach out to
them and how to make them you know
follow you
but if that happens and he
chooses to retweet your message
and then you see this
more than 6.26 million followers
and he is following 15.4
uh 15 400 individuals or accounts on
twitter
accounts would be a mix of individuals
and businesses
and a very active tweet
with the active twitter himself
right
so twitter is is vast it's amazingly
interesting and you know you can
these are some of the things that i
avoid spending too much time on because
i can very easily get sucked into it
there's so much information and there's
so much
data and there's so much variety you can
just keep immersing yourself into more
and more and more right
so to keep a discipline around how much
time you really should be spending as a
business
here is a recommendation
my advice is follow this recommendation
for about a week or two when you're
still new to using twitter for business
once you do that then you're going to
get into a natural rhythm and then you
will know what works best for you
so the idea is to follow for about 15
minutes
listen to conversations
uh you know offer your tweets
share information that people have been
already putting up so you engage with
the community
and you know you you engage with in
other ways besides sharing which is you
like
you comment
you uh you know you retweet you can do
all of that stuff so this is a
recommended split of time
you do this for some time you get you
need to do this to basically learn how
people are using twitter what people are
doing
and you will figure out what works best
for you
in in this way again please remember you
have to have very clearly what you know
your goals in mind why are you on
twitter
is it a broadcaster message is to get
traffic
is it to get traffic to your website or
is it to get traffic to your facebook
page what is it so depending on the
campaign depending on multiple things
your strategy might be different and
there is no one size fits all
right so you need to figure out what is
going to work best for you and use the
account accordingly with that we move on
to social networks
what is a good social authority
number to have
um
in general 70 plus is is ambitious
if you get 70 plus that means you are
already you know doing a lot of stuff on
twitter you're pretty active
your number your accounts are being your
uh your information is being shared
you are regular on twitter you have a
lot of followers but please remember
having the social authority according to
follower.followerwonk is not important
what is important is what is the traffic
and conversions that you are getting out
of your entire twitter exercise so what
is your goal
if your goal is to get a thousand
followers in a month then that's your
goal do what you have to do that but if
you have to really go further ahead and
that again is like likes on facebook it
is referred to as a vanity metric
it makes you look good
but what really matters is are you
getting the conversions that you desire
are people clicking on your tweets
coming to the landing page and doing
what you expect them to do which is why
you also should spend a lot of time
observing and following on to the kinds
of
messages people are tweeting the kinds
of landing pages people are promoting
through their twitter accounts in your
industry it again differs from industry
to industry
right so in your business your industry
what is really happening
are people using twitter to get traffic
only or are people using twitter to get
traffic and to encourage them to buy
something
or download a document or fill up a form
whatever that is
right so that is what should be your key
focus as you can see some of the very
big brands
uh do not have a ton of followers there
are individual celebrities entertainment
companies musicians
celebrity chefs politicians entertainers
they have a humongous amount of
following because they are in a
profession which is a public profession
very very news new c kind of work or you
know jobs that they do
so they general of curiosity
so it really depends on that
social networks
um
what do social networks give you you can
hand pick your connections
uh you have an access to extended
networks
you can broadcast networks as we saw on
on
twitter
and you basically receive communication
and information from your networks it's
a two-way
dialogue it isn't a monologue it isn't a
advertiser only platform it is a
conversational platform so it's like
walking into a party
you walk into a party you know a few
people uh you don't know a lot of people
you strike up conversations
you understand you know that between you
and some stranger there's a common
ground
and if that someone some stranger
happens to you know extend a business
card to you in the real world saying hey
this was it was a it was a pleasure
having a conversation give me a call
sometime and we can connect
an equivalent to that on social media is
getting fans is getting likes
um
social media call center yeah so there
are a lot of these things that are
emerging now which is essentially
extending your brand's presence beyond
the physical into the virtual
and again please remember you will keep
listening to a lot of interesting new
terms because people want to get noticed
so people will coin all kinds of new
terms to
uh you know for example growth hacking
is the latest buzzword happening in
digital marketing
um
and you know there's a lot of intrigue a
lot of curiosity around the term growth
hacking in fact there was a growth
hacking
meetup that i attended a month and a
half back
so these are all new terms new ways in
which people want to get their messages
across in a lot of cases it is the same
uh you know
traditional wisdom which doesn't change
how you connect with people in a regular
face-to-face interaction is a similar
way in which you will connect with
people on digital platforms as well so
fundamentals really don't change it is
about adapting to the specific platform
if you're connecting with somebody on
facebook you can afford to be a lot more
casual if you're connecting with
somebody who is definitely a business
contact on linkedin you might tend to be
a lot more formal than informal right so
again the tone depends which is similar
to what you will do in real life if you
go to a party you will talk about social
stuff you will talk about casual stuff
you might also mix in a little bit of
work based conversations
but if you meet a colleague or somebody
in a professional setting
you aren't really going to you might
have some you know
warm-up
contextual conversations like you know
it was it was raining on my way to work
or you know it's been a long weekend or
those kinds of you know small talk as we
call it to get the ball rolling but once
that happens then your focus of
conversations are a lot more formal so
it depends on the setting
very similarly it depends on which
platform you're using and you know how
you create those those those
relationships and that flapper so
social channels give you all these
options
you can communicate via multimedia
right
go ahead ask a question that's fine
uh status updates quick snippets of
content email style message systems
you have all these features typically on
your social platforms
right
so pankaj i'm assuming the question that
you're asking is in context to a job
application where you are applying for a
job as a digital marketer is that what
your was that the context yeah so this
is tricky okay because on social media
everything is public everything is open
if you say i am a heavy facebook user
then anybody can look up your profile on
facebook and see if you're indeed a
heavy user or not so the best way to be
able to establish
your
your footprint digitally in those areas
is by actually being active on these
channels so that would be the best way
to go about it
um
and of course in a in another context
you can also say that you know i'm new
i'm starting off but i've attended a
simply learned course so i'm certified i
know how to do it that was also going to
work okay
and people understand that if you're
looking at based on your profile you you
may have or may not have had the
opportunity to use every single tool out
there
but
um ideally people want to look at your
digital footprint
to tell
how much of a uh how much of social
channels do you follow
right so for example i am not very
active on facebook i am very active on
i'm not really but quite active on quora
i'm a lot more active on linkedin i'm
kind of active on twitter these are the
three platforms that i really use
uh when i'm in the mood when i'm for my
casual communication i use instagram i
take pictures and i tweet about them and
i and i put them up on instagram i
sparingly use pinterest but because of
all this you know i start getting
noticed people reach out to me people
send me invitations people include me in
lists so that is how your footprint is
you're able to expand your footprint on
the digital platform because it's all
there for people to see
right
so that's what it is
um
when you are looking at social media of
course
facebook is
right on top
immensely large
user base
more than in fact three billion internet
connections there are more than three
billion internet connections and
globally and 1.5 billion active monthly
users on facebook so
every second person that is on the
internet has a facebook account that's
how you might want to look at it
facebook is that popular
i'm just seeing there's anything else
that i want to share with you
okay
so
that's facebook
linkedin popular again
that's become the defect and the default
uh dynamic resume for today's times in
fact people use that more than they use
their formal resume
linkedin gives you a lot of information
there are over 350 million users
worldwide including 30 million users in
india alone
so um that is really the power of
linkedin
it's become like your online robotics so
you have those
back of visiting card flippers so those
those that was in the old times you
might still see that if you go to some
of the brick and mortar businesses and
offices
but linkedin has now become your online
roller deck so you can quickly skim
through your connections
look for connections with specific
keywords
look for people
and you know you have topical groups
and
for a b to b uh marketing
this is the business marketing social
media the the most powerful social media
happens to be linkedin
very effective way to get in
again what are people sharing updates
links images pictures
uh
connections um
videos
so very very popular so that's what you
typically do on your social media
and why does networking on social media
matter
it gives you great exposure
consumers speak freely you know there's
a lot of searchable chatter available
um and it's great for building the your
credibility as a brand as an individual
you can get a lot of click-throughs a
lot of instant conversions and
especially for people who want to share
blogs right blogs are informative so if
you're looking at building blog posts on
a variety of topics the top five
you know steps to doing this the the top
five stats in my industry uh you know
how to do this how to do that or
demonstrations of how to use a product
or opinions or trends or projections or
you know articles on information related
to industry
if that's the kind of information that
you're blogging about and you want
people to come and look at it
one very very powerful way of doing that
is by tweeting
the blog urls
using a twitter account and using the
right hashtags so by doing that you're
using
on twitter you get noticed and people
come in and read your blogs
similarly you can go to facebook you can
go to pinterest you can go to youtube
and all these channels and drive
conversions
conversions onto your landing page on
your website
these are all the reasons why you want
to use
uh you want to you want to leverage
social networking
in fact in today's times the way the
trends have moved is if you are
not on social media people tend to start
wondering are you trying to hide
something so that's how it is
for blogs wordpress seems to be the most
popular platform out there for two
reasons a the wordpress platform is very
very robust
and some of the leading brands like nasa
uses wordpress adobe one of the leading
technology companies they use wordpress
to build their own blog nasa's blog is
built on wordpress
so wordpress is you know a very powerful
platform
b uh there are a lot of plugins tools
and features that are built
with where with with minimal or no
programming effort you can integrate
those modules you can have a absolutely
stunning e-commerce website very complex
website
built fundamentally on wordpress
you can also use blogger that is for the
from a project perspective the idea is
for you to learn concepts so you use
blogger you use typepad you use any
platform for blogging it's absolutely
fine but if you really want to leverage
a blog platform to and you know
build a very very robust platform
to a large extent wordpress is your
solution especially for non-programmers
of course if you have the programming
jobs and if you want to go and build
large websites large commercial websites
or applications then you go beyond
wordpress and you use you know regular
programming code and you use other
technology platforms like drupal and
things like that
but if you are not very technically
heavy but you want to have a fairly
exhaustive
website with customer reviews baked in
with
seo with
conversion optimization av testing
uh and stuff like that you could
potentially go and use wordpress
um well wordpress depends on what
subscription of wordpress you take even
if you take a free wordpress account
and you host it then wordpress doesn't
really charge you that much wordpress i
mean i built blogs on wordpress for free
what i end up paying is for the domain
registration so if i have
www.mywebsite.com
and i want to host it on wordpress
then as a hosting service provider i
might pay you know a few dollars a few
20 30 40
and you know i can potentially go and
put that up
yeah so i see
uh okay
great so we will get into this uh
link pankaj at the break time remind me
because once i get in there i'm going to
get sucked into
looking at adding a lot of comments on
that so
i will look into that during the break
or towards the end of the session but
good that you posted that i'm sure a lot
of the other participants can also draw
some inspiration and get some ideas
on how you can start working on your
project
good stuff okay
understanding facebook so
congregation conversation and
publication of your content these are
the three primary reasons why you want
to use facebook
there are different kinds of pages that
you can build
as a business or as a brand
right if you're a brick and mortar
business for instance you create a local
business or this kind of a page
and then there are different pages i'm
in fact when we get into our facebook
section i'm going to go into these pages
in detail and walk you through how you
go about creating these pages
but fundamentally what you want to know
is that there are these primary types of
pages that you can build
based on your your existing presence if
you're a celebrity you use this
if you're a brand like an apple or a
nokia or something like that you might
use this as a brand page
each of these pages
the options that you get
to build these pages are unique to the
page type that you have chosen
that's the reason why there are these
many types if you're a government
organization institution school a
college
a company or a bank
then you might want to use this kind of
an option the options that you select
once you get into this type of page
creation is going to be unique to that
particular type of
business and then you have profiles and
i'm sure most of you in fact all of you
probably has a facebook profile if you
do not i would like to know just put
that on your chat but otherwise i'm
assuming that almost all of you have
facebook profiles right
so again you have pages that's what we
saw
exactly i mean even i use facebook
really at a personal level i don't use
facebook much otherwise
you can build groups you can build
communities
um you have what is called as the places
page so if you're a restaurant you have
about
six branches you have a restaurant main
main restaurant in one location and you
have five other branches in different
locations across the city across the
world
and you know each of those pages are the
places page for your main brand
uh that's an example of a places page
so these are the kinds of pages that
typically you can build and the kind of
presents that you can have on fb
so on social media what you want to do
is find who your fans are
and
use them to leverage them to spread your
word
so you have these kinds of follower
types right
so email your lists to invite them to
follow these are some best practices in
terms of how you want to
find fans and build your social
footprint
okay email your list inviting them to
follow you on your social media channels
it could be instagram it could be
pinterest twitter facebook whatever
include a link to follow you on facebook
right
in fact a lot of people do that people
put in their linkedin profile links on
their email signatures
companies that respond as customer
support departments will typically put
their telephone numbers and email id
which is fine but they also will now
include a link to their social media
twitter handle on their email uh email
itself rights so those are ways in which
you want to get traffic
to your website or to your social media
pages
right link from twitter from youtube
insert a widget into a blog so if you
look at you know uh there's a there's a
plugin called sumome and let me just
show that to you i think i covered this
nevertheless let me do that again
so if you use this
right it helps you build a
a plugin or an app that comes into your
blog page and clicking on that you can
actually share that page
so that's what it gives you as a feature
and you can go through all these details
to understand really what the features
are
it has a lot of
installation instructions how to do this
it's fairly structured
frequently asked questions
what can you do etc
screenshots of what your screen will
look like so if this is your blog
or your page on which you have activated
this free plugin
it will look like this it should take
your cursor there it's going to pop up
here
and you can sign up you can do multiple
things you can share that page
you can put up these kinds of you know
pop-up windows where you want to take
you want to take leads or take
subscriptions and that's what your leads
are
it can integrate with a bunch of other
tools it gives you an analytics of how
many people shared that page on twitter
how many people shared it on facebook
so you have all those sharing stats
right how many people uh you know
forwarded that by email
so there are a lot of features that
sumome basically enables for you
and of course you also want to get word
of mouth marketing
facebook fans broadcast if people like
your business they talk about it
you can give discounts
but i
adds use support property and
youtube advertising in in subsequent
modules where we will spend more time on
the advertising part of it which is the
paid
uh
way to basically get your friends and to
spread the word to build your
conversions and traffic
for a lot of brands for a lot of
businesses facebook ends up becoming a
secondary home to their brand
right
why because it's highly interactive
like your blog the facebook page now can
support a variety of media content
whether it is audio video images
you see that being supported
you have a lot of conversations going on
around your brand
and ultimately what is so important on
your facebook channel is the central
feed
why fees are so important here are some
interesting numbers
friends and family in fact the numbers
suggest that people do not really go to
your company
facebook page
but if they have liked your page or they
have interacted with your page by
assuming that you have a company page
then your tweets and when you get into
facebook i'm going to talk about the
facebook algorithm on how facebook
decides
which feed should be shown on to which
individual which post should be shown on
which individuals or which companies
news feed organically so i'm going to
get that in detail
but fundamentally you want to make sure
that your posts are appearing
in people's feeds why
that's reach that's unlimited exposure
again
there's credibility and no it's an
ongoing grade to build relationship
right this is an example of this brand
smart party and they have a
fairly vibrant
facebook presence
and where do people interact
these are the places
they click on this they like they follow
they share the message
they post they look at these they go
into the pictures they look at the top
tweet rather the top post
and they have liked so all of those
numbers come up here this of course is
the sponsored ad
section
again you're not unfamiliar to this if
you all have facebook profiles you know
how the interaction
happens on the newsfeed itself
again these are the numbers i was
talking about less than one percent
people see the post on the company page
they see the poll the majority of the
people
end up seeing the post on their own new
seeds right so if you make a post then i
see it on my newsfeed i don't really
come to your page to see that fee that's
what this number is
right the more you interact the more you
show up i'm going to get into those
details
at the right module but fundamentally
what you want to understand is the more
let us say you interact with me on
facebook
facebook assumes that you're important
to me and vice versa so you end up
seeing more of my facebook posts and i
see i end up seeing a lot more of your
facebook posts based on the number of
times we have exchanged each other's uh
information on facebook so there's a
very complex algorithm that goes beyond
but that's in a very simplistic way
that's really what happens
which is why you might notice that even
if you have 500 friends on facebook
there are 15 20 people's posts that you
routinely see you don't see everybody's
posts all the time
okay
and then you also want to put together
an ad strategy
based on what is it that you want to
achieve
demonstrating the variety in numbers
100 shares an average of 130 friends for
each person who has
shared your message
and that is the potential exposure that
your post could potentially get
right
the facebook ads really worth it
the same question could go for google as
well so the point is this right
um you got to know how to use it if you
know how to use it well then you will
see the right roi
so this course is all about that i'm
going to teach you on how you need to
and also based on this
you are you know kind of get a sense of
how you need to build the kind of ads
and oh yes facebook ads can be extremely
powerful but again you need to get the
context for a b2c market facebook ads
work very very well
for b2b
the conversion rate may not be that much
because in a b2b session in a b2b
setting
you know sales cycles are typically
longer
and just having an ad isn't going to be
enough for somebody to
come in and buy a product but if you're
selling a product to a retail con
consumer or customer
then a facebook ad can be more
productive
yeah yeah
that's why so it depends really on the
market
uh i mean when i'm on facebook i keep
getting a lot of invitations by brands
that talk about you know digital
marketing seminars webinars and things
like that which is my idea of interest
so i do pay attention and i do look at
those ads
yeah that's what it is
so again on facebook if you use the
right kind of marketing strategy
then your facebook ads can be fairly
productive
facebook ads you see this suggested post
this is marketing stuff it's come by the
brand called marquito and then these are
also your ads
this is an example of an ad showing in
the news feed
so again an example if you want to
target new contacts and if this is a
post by rustic wedding chic
let me just
see if i can show that to you
so this is the brand rustic wedding
shirt this is their facebook page
as you can see
a lot of people have liked it there are
multiple options for engagement and
interaction they've been around since 20
i can write something and i can put it
up there i can message the page or the
brand i can like i can sign up to the
newsletter and subscriptions
these are all the things that i can do
this is data about the brand
and these are messages that they are
promoting so they say you're so excited
to finally be able to share the whatever
the perfect pair and as you can see even
on facebook you can use these hashtags
to get discovered
and if i click on this this is the page
where the conversion is going to happen
right so
this is a post and you see this that put
up a post here
it's coming by the rustic wedding
chic.com brand
let's put up some more information
they'll put this up here
as you can see there are 13 people who
have liked and shared these are the
individuals concerned who have really
taken the trouble to
share this information on this page
so they keep they seem to be circulating
a lot of
uh messages on an ongoing routine basis
right
this is the landing page that we saw on
the previous uh
post and there's an entry form and in
this case let us say they would
typically want you to fill up the form
and the filling of the form could be the
goal or the conversion for that
particular post and that's part of this
brand's
social media strategy
okay
so in this example rustic wedding has
put up a picture of this this particular
gown and there's a note here and this
already has been liked by 102 people
and there's a lot of people who've
commented on this
so rustic wedding sheikh might decide
that they want to boost this particular
post
this post organically got a lot of
traction
now they see that if this is gaining
popularity more and more people seem to
be liking this now i would like to take
this message
and use this as an advertisement to
attract people
on facebook who do not know me yet
and this is an example of what the
targeting for this particular post could
look like
so i could choose a location
right down to the postal code of the zip
code
i can select the age demographic
within which i want to target my
audience whether they are men women or
otherwise
i can select precise interests now what
facebook does is that based on your own
profile details that you have entered
which school you went to what did you do
which group are you part of
which ice cream do you like
what have you liked what which community
are you part of
you are profiled by facebook right
facebook says that you're individuals
with these interests these schools
this education these preferences etc etc
depending on
the detail to which you have shared your
own information on fb on facebook
based on that
if you put in these words
at weddings antiques roadshow country
living
then a lot of these options pop up
automatically
on the facebook tool and then you can
look at suggested likes and interests
and add them to your target
now if you do that if you keep adding
this similar to pinterest well way more
powerful but if you keep adding these
options here
as you can see on the right hand side
your audience
keeps growing
and it tells you people who live in the
united states exactly between these ages
who are females or ladies who like these
topics who are engaged
and who are not already connected which
means you're going beyond your existing
fan list
right so this is basically the way you
build targeting
uh
i will show you where you do this on
facebook
so this is my facebook personal account
but i could also go into a um
the company page that i manage
right
and let us say i put up a post as a
business
as a company
i put up this post i was invited to
speak at a university in india last year
so i'm seeing this okay
and i want to boost this i see that this
has reached 23 people there are so many
views people liked it whatever it is
and i want to promote this so then i
click on boost post
now as the admin or the owner of this
particular page or this account
i can get to select all those targeting
options if i click on boost post that is
one way of doing it there's also the way
in which i can go and create an
advertisement
[Music]
so in this case you see this i can say
people who have liked my page
well
when you create a boost then it is not
free you have to set up a price of
budget
so
yeah this is this is paid advertising
now you're going beyond organic you're
looking at paid advertising right so
i'll show you the targeting or target an
audience targeting so here you see this
i who should be my audience
now i've already selected audience one
which is a profile that i created some
time back
and this profile says all this the
location is this
interests are these age group is this
and
if i choose to have my budget of seven
dollar dollars a day
then my estimator reaches 300 to 200
people
if i'm willing to spend 27 dollars a day
my estimated reaches 950 to two and a
half thousand people on facebook who fit
my targeting criteria
you see this
it tells you
what is the range correct yeah what is
the range of uh
yeah yeah that's what i have i use that
uh to basically demo a lot of stuff that
i do
so this is this gives you a range of the
number of people you can reach and the
kind of activity you can do
so you can define the duration should be
7 days 14 days or run this ad until this
particular date
30th of june
okay
and i end up spending this much
approximately per day based on the
budget that i have selected
and then i choose how i want to pay for
this ad do i pay canadian dollars do i
pay in british pounds
right it gives me all of those options i
can add a new method of payment i can
add my credit card so that is how this
becomes a boosted or a sponsored post
on the desktop feed this is how my page
is going to look my post is going to
look like this
it will come up with this word sponsored
right
or on mobile news feeds
this is how my page will or the post
will look
so if i get into more
details in terms of the targeting then i
have already gone through all these
options which is how i arrived at that
potential audience that i could reach
okay
so that's how you do this as i said on
the post you look at this you look at
the estimated reach and that's how you
go about promoting of course on the
facebook module i'm going to give you a
lot more details i want to walk you
through the steps of creating ads and
how you go about creating pages but this
is to give you a quick overall glimpse
of how you know
it works
any questions so far
so carol uh twitter handle is basically
nothing but the name of your twitter
page that's what it is it's it's called
as a twitter handle
harish is saying if we create our page
we ask facebook to increase lives how to
impact
our business
um as i said there are multiple things
to just getting likes on facebook
how to ask for likes is also something
that i will
uh share with you when you hit the
facebook section in more detail okay
then so there's a very nice way of
asking without having to ask and we will
see some case studies and examples
you